[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
nor is that Furtick of it dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast for me and my
brother John we answer your questions we
give you to be this advice and we bring
you all the week's news from both Mars
and AFC Wimbledon how you doing John I'm
doing well it's the end of the year here
in the United States and in much of the
world and I have to say I am happy that
this year is ending it's been a good
year in many ways AFC Wimbledon became a
third tier soccer team but I do not
believe that I'm going to look back on
2016 either either personally or in a
larger sense as the time of my life I'm
hoping that 2017 will somehow manage to
be better yes well don't count your
chickens before the days done Hatchin I
got a baby out of 2016 so that's not
nothing
and and and what a cute baby by the way
last night say I was showing me pictures
of your son and he's so much cuter than
our children whereas infants but you
know the arc of history is long and it's
too soon to declare winners that's right
that's right but I'm glad that we agree
that we're having a competition the Sun
the Sun came out today in Montana which
is I forgot that it existed because we
had not seen it in a while and I
realized the reason why I didn't want to
go outside for so long it was because it
was terrible but now I feel like I need
to go also I threw my back out bouncing
my giant baby he came out Big John and
he's a giant
he's a large child and I yeah so I'm
glad glad to be feeling that way though
I have a bunch of work to do so I
probably won't be able to do much
outside stuff which is a bummer also I
haven't seen rogue one or arrival or
fantastic beasts or a number of other
movies that have come out that I've
heard are very very good and I tell you
the two best movies of the year in my
opinion I'm incredibly fortunate Hank I
get most of the major Oscar contenders
sent to my house and DVD for free send
me I feel bad how great it is it is
really great and I'm very grateful to
the people who do that but anyway having
watched most of the major Best Picture
contenders
I have to say there are a lot of really
good movies this year but to me far and
away the two best films of the year
are hidden figures which is about some
of the african-american women who did a
lot of the calculations that allowed
Alan Shepard to go into space
and moonlight which is maybe the best
movie I've seen in like 10 years I
haven't seen a movie like moonlight in a
long long time it's a very special film
and so rogue one is awesome arrival is
awesome I hope you get to see both those
movies but I really hope you get to see
hidden figures in moonlight all right
well if I could suggest any any movie to
anybody this year it would be
Independence Day resurgence cuz I heard
that one did really well hey would you
like a short poem for today I'm not even
gonna dignify that with a response has
to do it do it John hey do you know what
today's poems about that about death no
do you know what does it call death no
do you know what it's called
oh I don't it's called the chipmunk by
Ogden Nash I almost got there I would
given me one more I would have been like
is it about the Wikipedia of chipmunks
Mahnke pedia no the great American monka
pedia poem is still yet to be written
but the great American chipmunk poem has
been written it was written by Ogden
Nash and it goes like this my friends
all know that I am shy but the chipmunk
is twice as shy as I he moves with
flickering indecision like stripes
across the television he's like the
shadow of a cloud or Emily Dickinson
read aloud yet his ultimate purpose is
obvious very to get back to his chip
monastery the chipmunk by Ogden Nash
America's great chipmunk poem your roam
and it makes it it makes me think that
that chipmunks are called chipmunks
because they build giant buildings out
of potato chips
and they worship chips
yeah you know Ogden a shank he's also
responsible for such clever couplets as
candy dandy but liquor is quicker
correct though that is not actually
accurate because no matter how much
candy you eat you ain't gonna get drunk
that's true that's a good point
hey let's answer some questions from our
listeners that sounds like a fine idea
though though do you not want to point
out that the the monka pedia twitter
tweeted us to let us know that we had
gotten some facts wrong about Simon's
glasses I listen if we spend the rest of
the podcast correcting all the mistakes
that we made about Simon's glasses this
is going to become a full-time Simon's
glasses podcast we need to get to the
questions from our listeners we had the
chipmunk call back it was beautiful it
was brilliant we need to move on
okay okay John our first question is
from Sarah who asks dear Hank and John I
was thinking about a Hanks ice breaking
question what's your favorite bridge
which I stand by and I was trying to
come up with my own unusual question to
pose to new acquaintances I have finally
come up with my own out-of-the-box
question so I posed this query to you if
you were a ghost
what building would you haunt think
about it carefully because no one knows
if ghosts are allotted two weeks
vacation per year 40-hour work week you
will be expected to work overtime
indefinitely happy haunting Sarah have
you thought about this question genre or
should I go first you can go first I do
have an answer I would like to haunt the
Haunted Mansion at Disneyworld oh that's
just a terrible idea
why not everybody's like oh it's so
spooky and then I'll be like no I'm for
real
hi I'm Hank I was famous on the internet
back back in the early 2000s I mean
here's my issue with that Hank on a
practical level do you really want to
haunt a building where the exact same
thing happens all day long eight minutes
after eight minutes after eight minutes
for eternity I mean that's as close to
hell as you can possibly get without
being on hell well you know it's changed
over the years a little bit
and I I like the idea of I'm just a
people watcher I enjoy looking at people
and I like the idea of seeing the sort
of changing demographics of the Haunted
Mansion over the millennia that there's
this consistency in the the in the
building itself and in the experience
but a difference in the people who
attend and the experiences that they
have based on their own terrible life
experience III think that that has a lot
going for it also you know I don't want
to scare people too bad so I kind of
wanted to be ready to be haunted I mean
what's so interesting to me about your
answer is that my answer is is very
nearly the opposite answer which is as
follows the most remote island atoll in
the world is called Saguaro and it's in
the South Pacific course you know that
halfway between South America and
Australia truly in the middle of nowhere
extremely hard to get to and this guy
Tom Neal lived alone in a single
building on Anchorage Island in that a
toll for like 30 years in two separate
trips he lived there once alone for
seventeen years where he was visited
like ten times by yachts and other
people traveling over the course that's
seventeen years and then he went back
for like another decade plus and he
ended up almost dying on the island but
when he had stomach cancer he got
brought back to the Cook Islands for
treatment he died there so anyway there
is a single building on use one on the
unanchored Island in this Morrow at all
and that is the building that I would
like to haunt because I would be living
in so far as you know you're living
after you're dead in a beautiful beachy
in credible great weather just
everything perfect and best of all I
would be alone so I wouldn't have to
haunt anyone oh you know what John I
honestly thought that you're gonna say
your own house and but that before you
died if you knew you were gonna be a
ghost you'd say I'm gonna hop my house
and also it's going to be held in in
forever trust by this this this you know
some kind of
some kind of I don't know what what kind
of financial institution would just own
your house forever but that and then you
would just continue to haunt your own
home forever
because you do like it at home yeah I
mean that's appealing except I don't
want to spend eternity in Indianapolis
you got another question John I do this
question comes from Ali who writes dear
John and Hank I'm very confused by the
US government deficit well I'm glad
you've come to your favorite advice
podcast Ali great choice everyone on the
Left keeps saying that deficit is going
down well everyone on the right says it
is going up please help shed some light
on this topic well I think that well
Emily yeah I think the problem is the
word going we just start we're no we're
no good at words and we sure do like to
abuse Kate one of my favorite word's
I don't actually think that's the
problem because the deficit is only
going in one direction which is down
it's just that it's still much greater
than zero which means that it is
continuing to add to the overall size of
the national debt which is going up and
has gone up you know pretty consistently
for like 35 years yeah the budget
deficit is going down every generation
the thing you need to you need to
explain is what is the deficit because
because it is confusing the difference
between the debt and the deficit okay
great yeah so the the deficit is the
difference between the amount of money
that the federal government spends on
roads and bridges and prisons and
schools and whatever else and the amount
of money it takes in mostly in the form
of taxes and in any given year in a gray
year right in any given year so you know
if we spend a trillion dollars but we
only take in nine hundred billion
dollars we would have a one hundred
billion dollar deficit in fact we spend
and taken much more than that but anyway
so the debt is the overall amount of
money that the US government owes mmm
weirdly a lot of the money that the US
government owes it to itself which is a
little bit different from how like you
know household debt functions but also a
lot of it is held
individuals who purchase government
bonds or t-bills and then a lot of it is
also held by foreign governments but we
also own a lot of foreign government
debt it's a little complicated but the
deficit is the amount of money that we
are coming up short each year in our
budget and the debt is the overall like
size of our outstanding obligations as a
government right so the deficit has gone
down every year since 2011 it has gone
down again this year so when you hear
people so when you hear people on the
Left saying the deficit is going down
that's true when you hear people on the
right say the deficit is going up
they're probably actually saying that
the debt is going up which is also true
as usual it's complicated and it really
depends on your perspective whether the
size of our debt out let me say one
other thing Ike the only other thing I
want to say is that smart people with
PhDs in economics disagree about how
much debt is safe to have and I do not
know the answer to that question and I
think neither does anyone really I think
that there is an amount which is too
much and there is an amount which is too
little but there is yeah there is an
amount that is too little and there is
an amount that's too much the problem
with the amount that's too much is that
you don't really know until you hit it
mm-hm and once you hit it it is almost
impossible to do anything to stop a debt
spiral that the level of catastrophe
that that would involve is genuinely
unimaginable let's move on to another
question this one comes from Barbara
Wright skank as I am a working mom of
two I rarely have time to myself so I
have started to consume social media and
YouTube videos mainly on the toilet or
in the tub since then I've been
wondering how youtubers feel about
people taking them to these places are
you okay with it or would you rather
fans wouldn't do that uh I don't need to
know necessarily but you can consume my
content wherever you like I and yeah
that's how I feel too
Barbara as long as you're watching ads
no I'm just kidding that's fine you
don't have an ad blocker on your toilet
phone
hello I think it's very hard to be it's
so hard to be a working parent it's so
hard to find time for yourself for the
media that you like and if the toilet is
the place for that totally cool with it
thank you for including me in your life
however you do it here's another
question John it's from RJ dear Hank and
John I am a freshman finals are coming
and I am a burned out candle how do I
get the nice little reset that I need so
I can successfully cram all the
information I need for the tests thank
you for sharing your advice on how to
deal with stress and general candle
feelings
alright RJ we're going to take a stake
right now we're gonna have it with the
hold sound and it's a lot it is
oftentimes a lot of energy here on tier
hanka John but for you we're gonna take
it down a notch got chill out a little
bit and we're just gonna say RJ you're
doing good
you're doing fine you're working hard
you care you're passionate you know that
you need to work hard and you're gonna
work you're gonna do the hard work and
then you're gonna take a couple breaths
with me you're just gonna go in go keep
going in and in in in in and out take it
yet nice long breath nice get back to
work RJ that is exactly what Hank does
he allows himself three breaths and then
he starts screaming at himself again I'm
gonna have a slightly different advice
which is that okay if you feel like a
burnt out candle you need two things
right you need some wax so that you can
like refill the candle and then you need
a source of light like a spark or you
need to basically argue I think what you
need to do is go to Target and buy some
paraffin wax and a lighter and you're
gonna be back in business
[Laughter]
it's such great advice John I should
never should never even try to answer
these questions do you want to give us
another question I know god I mean we've
been doing this for a year and a half
and I finally feel like we're properly
properly dubious like we've finally
gotten bad
we were never good at podcasting but
this is the first time when I felt like
we've been genuinely bad this question
comes from anonymous who writes Dear
John and Hank my brother's birthday is
coming up and I am stumped as to what to
get him
he's turning 21 and I just got him the
dad's Bob podcast perk from the project
for awesome IndieGoGo but I feel like
it's necessary to get him something to
go along with it he listens to dear Hank
and John so ideally don't mention my
name or anything you can call me
whatever you please mmm all right
Francine listen up the number one thing
you should have done was let us know in
your question what your brother's name
is so that we could wish him a happy
birthday also Hank can we go back to our
J's question and just acknowledge that
finals are over and so whatever piece of
advice you gave RJ is completely useless
that just occurred to me but like that's
in the past now that's a great pun as
this person I'm sorry RJ I'm sure
Francine's brother if you recently had a
21st birthday and you loved the pod
maybe your sibling wishes you a happy
birthday from us but maybe not we have
no way of telling because the question
is from anonymous and they did not list
your name so so I III kind of face it is
your 21 year old brother a recent father
or or did you just get him the
fatherhood podcast because I could you
didn't tell us anything about this guy
we need to know something yeah I feel
very under informed about Francine's
brother yeah uh if he's a recent father
I can tell you what what you should what
you should acquire because the only
thing that is necessary is is is
blankets things to mop things up with
just washcloths towels clothes yeah just
everything is covered and sticky and and
and I'm pretty sure that that I've got
like a like a thin film of spit up and
poop covering my entire body despite the
fact that I literally just got out of a
shower not literally I mean you've been
podcasting for sale just is subjective
John well then why I add the litter my
hair is still wet call attention to hair
is still wet I
pod in the shower John you don't know
you know what I'm thinking right now
Hank to be totally honest with you I'm
thinking that we need to go back to
Manke pedia for some inspiration because
this is weak sauce
[Laughter]
so obviously chipmunks paraphernalia is
good for anyone of any age of any gender
of any nationality oh my god I have to
tell you something related to chipmunks
paraphernalia two things actually first
a couple days ago you tweeted with a
picture of a glass of an Alvin and the
Chipmunks glass that you had and you
were like this is my Alvin and the
Chipmunks class I can't believe I didn't
bring it up earlier and you and I both
know that that is my Alvin and the
Chipmunks glass from our share you know
John I don't I don't know that that's
true because I had one that I got from
home and then I bought a set I bought
the other two on eBay so I'm not sure if
it was Theodore that we had our phones
alvin and simon it may have been alvin
in which case this is similar to how you
sold my baseball cards on ebay it is
just another example of how when I leave
the house for five seconds you assume
that all of my possessions suddenly
belong to you anyway secondly the other
thing I forgot to mention about Alvin
and the Chipmunks is that my children
whom I love have recently acquired three
animatronic chipmunks Alvin Simon and
Theodore dressed as Santa's and you push
a button and they sing like at least
nine minutes of Christmas carols and
what the kids do because I don't like
they have a different relationship with
sensation than I do is they push all
three buttons so Alvin Simon and
Theodore are singing cause Harold's at
each other in chipmunk voices while the
music is clashing and the kids are
jumping up and down and screaming and
singing along to this song and that song
and like the level of sensory input is
such that like a man could wish to
become a ghost haunting anchorage island
in saguaro so so a couple of things to
add to her conversation one
I said that I have bad news regarding
the Alvin glass it's gone it's it
perished secondly did you know I found
this out as doing a little bit of
research that Alvin and the Chipmunks
are actually hamsters no no way yes the
actors who play a lot in the chipmunks
are hamsters there are no actors it's
what do you it's an animated television
program there is like what actors actors
who play there are happiness there they
work cheaper there they're less
expensive did you did you read this at
snopes.com I did it's a false as the
first word of the story what do you mean
the actors are hamsters which to which
which actors are editing the onion in my
brain I have I have a brain onion just
like stories that my brain has it's like
not as funny as the real onion but it's
always delivering okay can we really
quickly before we get back to questions
from our listeners can we swap all-time
favorite onion headlines Oh probably not
because I don't like store onion
headlines in my brain oh I do I do i I
have like I have like a top 30 okay so
it's it's possible that we've done
enough chipmunk stuff we should answer
another question okay yeah let's let's
let's move on away from chipmunks okay
this question is from Anna and I know
that it's honor because it says at the
end of this it says Anna like the
princess so oh man if I could just
correct you really quickly Oh how's your
daughter she dresses up as Princess Anna
almost every day she either dresses up
as Princess Elsa or Princess Anna every
day and whenever I look at her and she's
dressed in her princess on a costume I
always say princess on of arendale it's
so nice to see you and do you know what
Alice says what she says I'm gonna have
to get away from the microphone to
recreate Alice's voice because if she
does not speak she only screams and this
is what she says daddy
is it and I'm always like well not I
mean not in the in the movie it's
princess honor and then she just I'll be
like Alice I think it I think it is
actually honor Wow
I've got some things to look forward to
uh uh asks you do dear Hank and John I
would very much like to be a kind person
I believe and hope that kindness is a
choice rather than an innate talent but
for all my trying I feel I am very bad
at it I am NOT very emotionally
intelligent and while I have strong
general feelings about kindness I'm not
clear on the exact details of what it
entails I don't know how could you
please give me some practical advice on
how to be genuinely kind to people kind
regards Anna like the princess that's a
great that's a great sign of kind
regards it's almost as good yeah it was
a quote there was some there was some
quotation marks for kind the kind oh I
didn't even get the pun I'm not very
clever I don't know Hank you're kinder
than I am so maybe you should answer
this question you highlighted this
question so I thought you had a good
answer but I'll take it go it's it's a
is definitely a muscle that that gets
stronger with flexing it is also it
requires a great deal of giving of the
benefit of the doubt and assuming that
people are basically good and and also
realizing that when you feel as if you
are the you know at this short end of
the world stick that there is a lot of
bias that goes into that and I say this
is a person who is at the at the longest
end of the world stick but the Malik
that has helped me be a kinder person
that like I have had lots of really
great experiences and have been around a
lots of really good people but to me it
is it is about exercising thoughtfulness
and empathy and also taking time to like
consider the interactions you've had
that day and whether whether you in the
end had a positive impact on the people
that you interacted with
and that doesn't have to be like oh they
thought that I was so cool and funny
because that's like ego feeding it's
like did they feel better after they
were hanging out with you after they
spent time with you that's to me what
what you're going for and what kindness
is kind of about is how can I interact
with people in a way that they feel
better afterward because that's the only
way that everybody's going to feel
better in the end right but that is very
hard to do practically I'm struggling
with virtue or trying to work on
something in my own life it helps to
reframe it into language like into
different language sometimes so I often
try to think of kindness as generosity
like is there a way that I could be more
generous in my responses to people in my
daily interactions in my professional
relationships and my personal
relationships and the answer is almost
always you know yes there are lots of
ways that I'm very straightforwardly and
to easily be more generous so that's
what I need to be doing but I I agree
that it's it's something that gets
better the more you do it it is very
hard practically to be kind because
practically most of the time you respond
or I respond and I think most people
respond to anger with anger or to
frustration with frustration it's almost
impossible to respond to anger with
generosity but if you can flip that
script there's a great episode of
invisibie Leah about this if you can
flip that script it can be sort of
miraculous and I've had people flip that
script on me when I've had been having
such a bad day like I've recently made a
video about this woman named Carmen who
when I didn't get to see Hamilton and I
was completely devastated totally
flipped the script on me and reminded me
of all the great things in my life and
the fact that I've got the basics
covered and when people can do that for
you it's such a gift and so I think
noticing generosity in your own life can
maybe also help you reflect it back to
other people alright and there's also
something to be said for
like if you if like it's very hard to
respond to anger or frustration with
kindness but it's easier to respond to
indifference with kindness yeah and so
just doing something nice to someone who
like otherwise you baby wouldn't have
had an interaction with it all Minh like
feeling the feeling that that gives you
and also like I really think that it
there is a lot to be said for spending a
little bit of time thinking about what
happened that day and the things that
you did the interactions that you had
and like how you could have done them
better and I don't think that like it
can be really hard to find time to do
that with and also it can it's really
important to not try and have that time
be the moments before you go to sleep
because that can cause a good deal of
insomnia but like giving yourself a
little bit of space to be like yeah like
if you can write that stuff down like
journal writing or blogging or whatever
because I have a vet so hard for me to
to think all of the thoughts that I need
with the space that's in my head and
having a piece of paper or a blank
screen lets me have a little bit more
like RAM like spaced in which to think
and like go back and see but I was just
thinking this but I had forgotten that
I've been thinking that kind of thing
and in self-reflection is very important
and we have less and less space for it
in our lives right now and I think that
it's a really big part of kindness and
also practice especially practice
talking to strangers and being kind of
strangers because a lot of times like it
can just be anxiety inducing and it's
taken me 35 years to be able to do it
without being like oh god I did I gonna
screw this up
did I say 35 because I'm 36 years old
yeah I was gonna correct you but that
wouldn't have been very coming with me
you know somewhat related but mostly
tangential thing every year Sarah and I
write two letters we write a letter back
to ourselves at the beginning of the
year about everything that happened that
year and you know I go back and look
through my Google Calendar and through
the videos that we made and through lots
of other stuff to talk about what
happened that year what went well what
what
poorly what were the unexpected
challenges and then we write a letter to
are kind of like cells at the end of
that year outlining our goals and
priorities and what we want to focus on
this year and that's been so helpful
like of everything I've ever done in my
life that's like gross and therapy ish
and and III do a lot of that stuff even
though I dislike it because it works of
all that stuff that's been the thing
that's most helpful is looking back
celebrating accomplishments and the
journey that you've had over the last
year and then also looking forward and
making you know achievable goals that
are well-defined and you know it's
really worked for us that's a great
that's a great great idea I think that
that's a really practical and like
achievable thing that you know once a
year and we have more time around the
holidays often to do that kind of thing
not everybody but who truly spoken like
somebody who just became a father right
now my child means very little from me
mostly cuddles so anyhoo ya know it's in
a way parenting an infant is the hardest
because oh my god it's so hard but in
another way it's so straightforward all
they need is all they need is cuddles
and occasional like food and diaper
changes actually now that I think about
it I it is really hard this is this is
way more fun once they can talk to you
and read Harry Potter books it's so much
so much more fun yeah we started to have
been able to have like some some
interactions with Oren where it feels
like we do something and he responds and
it's like that's so cool like in a
positive way way I could I could always
make him cry if I needed to
why did I say that
yeah so let me explain myself sometimes
he falls asleep and he needs to continue
eating I have cold hands most of the
time because it's Montana and it's the
winter and I will put my hand on his
head so that he will wake up a little
bit and I'm like well I can I can at
least make I could you will respond
two negative stimulus but now he will
respond to positive stimulus and that's
like all neat so I apologize for victim
lighting the pictures of him smiling are
just they're just they just make me melt
inside which reminds me that today's
podcast is brought to you by baby babies
they're quite a lot of work yes indeed
today's podcast was also brought to you
by the paraffin and lighters section at
your local target department store which
is not what they call targets I don't
know why I that's what they're doing now
they're calling them department stores I
changed my mind
there's departments and it's a store
your local Target department store it
has a department just for unn burning
out your candles with paraffin and
lighters dot-com then of course today's
podcast is also brought to you by the
Haunted Mansion ride at Disney World the
Haunted Mansion ride at Disney World so
fun that apparently Hank wants to spend
eternity there
and finally this podcast is brought to
you by the chipmunk glass that we got
probably at a fast-food restaurant in
the 1980s that John and I apparently
still co-owned I mean I would say that
it's mine because it is but it is
currently in your house well how is it
yours mine how is it is mine if for no
other reason than you have without
permission or consultation taking it
from our ancestral home and put it in
your home rather than consulting with me
about who cares more about that chipmunk
glass which is obviously me since I just
made my annual pledge to monka pedia the
number one chipmunk Wikipedia source on
the Internet okay John I actually did
first and I know that now the monkey PD
enters are listening and they're
probably like where's that donation
check listen up monka pedia if you're a
registered 501 C 3 contact me about a
small very small extremely small
donation and I will I will hook you up
if and only if Hank returns that glass
to me oh wow wow wow now work that work
now really the media if you don't get a
check for me that's on Hank
okay well I
I will say that I cared enough to take
these glasses that were probably from
Wendy's and were definitely from 1985
and get the other two so that I could
have a complete set well I mean I would
love to have even one of the three but
unfortunately well that opportunity was
did it turns out there were four there
was a there's in in true and true a you
know 1985 American fashion there's one
for one for Alvin one for Simon one for
Theodore and one for all three of the
Chipettes they have to share a cup you
know what I just discovered him and this
is this is a surprise to me those 1985
that full set of the 1985 Alvin and the
Chipmunks Wendy's glasses are available
on eBay for $12 yeah no they were not
expensive so maybe I should stop whining
and just put that $12 out into the world
and enjoy the glasses that by the way
Sarah would never let into our kitchen
cabinets I'm really disturbed by the
fact that it appears more and more like
these Chipmunks glasses are from
Hardee's bodies when I was a child no I
don't know that we had them oh man you
know what's most distressing about
Hardee's Hank is that their CEO is gonna
be our next labor secretary let's move
on to a question from our listeners okay
this question comes from Brooke who
writes Dear John and Hank I'm a parent
to three children my oldest is in second
grade and yesterday her teacher
contacted me to let me know that she's
been bullying another student I was and
still am in shock what can I do to help
her understand that bullying is not
acceptable
I want to stop this behavior before it
gets any worse and make sure that my
other two children don't follow a
similar path I was bullied as a child
and could give advice for days on how to
deal with that but I'm at a loss at how
to deal with the other side of this
awful coin well first of all I have to
thank you for the question and also for
taking it seriously that there is a
problem where a lot of parents will hear
that their child from from a school
or in some other way that their child
has been bullying people and
automatically look for reasons why it
wasn't their child's fault or or you
know indeed the child probably has
reasons why it wasn't their fault even
if it's a second grader people are
really good explaining all of their
actions even if they are unkind so thank
you and and and we call a lot of
attention to like the the difficulties
of the people who are being bullied but
there you know the way and you might say
to like the person who's doing the
bullying why don't you just stop doing
that and you know like the only people
who can stop the bullying are the people
doing the bullying and so we need to
figure them out and understand that and
also figure out how to like have good
conversations with them I my child is
two months old so I have no idea
practically but I think that it I have
managed humans they are not second
graders so take this with all of the
grains of salt but I I would say that
you like you have to do your best to
understand the situation the particular
situation and so you can talk about that
particular practical situation whether
you're able to talk about that with the
teacher who called you or even some of
the other children involved that would
be really great so that you can have a
frank conversation with your child about
like what they did why they did it and
why it was wrong and like this isn't
something that's necessarily like going
to come naturally like empathy is hard
and it's a complicated process and and
I'll mess up like no one correctly
interprets fairness a hundred percent of
the time sometimes we think that what
someone has done to us is
disproportionate to what we did to them
when in fact it wasn't in sometimes we
don't realize that our reaction to
someone else was extraordinarily
disproportionate especially if we are a
second grader so I I think that there is
that that it's a chance to have maybe a
little bit difficult conversation but a
conversation about how to be kind to
people and to think about them in a more
complex way and that's going to be like
a lifelong learning experience for your
child just like it was for you just like
it was for everyone but I think that you
clearly have caught like have come out
this fight are coming at this from a
compassionate place you need to be an
example of compassion for your children
but like that's not always going to be
everything you also have to create those
moments for talking and reflecting about
that stuff I just hit the microphone I'm
sorry and then of course if this baby
havior continues there are like places
you can go people you can talk to and
there's stop it's the stop bullying now
website is a really good website where
you can read things that are from people
who are experts and are not just
podcasters who mostly talk about
chipmunks and death yes I agree
especially with the last the last thing
that he said but in general I think that
was a great advice
I mean dubious but for you good you know
the the the the eastern chipmunk of the
United States uh only lives about three
years before dying well I mean you can
say that the eastern chipmunk of the
United States only lives about three
years before dying but I think we all
know that Simon and the Chipmunks are
eternal Hank it's time to move on I like
that you just put Simon in charge of the
chipmunks you're like Simon's in charge
yeah it's no more Alvin now it's it's
Simon show it's Simon
and to a lesser extent Alvin and
Theodore that is my understanding of the
way it's gonna work from here on out
now that you've totally changed the
history of the Chipmunks franchise via
our podcast Hank let us move on now to
the all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon oh gosh I don't even know
where to start well it was gone so much
happened on Mars that it is difficult
did it there's just all kinds of radical
changes shut up is unbelievable
uau I mean it's a vastly different place
than it was two weeks ago the big news
right now is about these geographical
formations that that happened in the
polar region where they're basically it
appears like some kind of carbon dioxide
erosion and they they come in like they
form in these like spider webby looking
things and they're cut they have called
them colloquially the spiders and people
right now today the day we're recording
this are kind of freaking out in there
like the spiders the spiders on Mars
like like Ziggy Stardust which is indeed
but but the thing that I didn't get to
talk about that it's just so cool so
cool
while I was on paternity leave is that
curiosity driving across the surface of
Mars it's like boop de doop I'm awesome
robot on Mars and they spot on the
ground a weird-looking rock and it turns
out that they have found on the surface
of Mars this foreign planet that we have
covered like we have looked at you know
tiny tiny percent of a percent of a
percent of and it comes across what is a
meteorite a piece of space junk that
fell to the surface of Mars like a
fraction of a meteorite it like like the
kind of thing that would be
extraordinarily rare to find here on
earth easier to find on Mars because
there's less geological process or less
you know I guess geological process
covering those things up but they they
were able to like take a look at it it's
a it you know the meteorite on the
surface of Mars so like a piece like a
like on this foreign planet there's
another piece of rock that is foreign to
that foreign planet and we were able to
take a pretty dope picture of it and
study it and learn something about its
composition which is that it's pretty
common type of meteorite and and then
move on and be like way we can come back
to that whatever we actually when some
humans are here and they could be like
ah this is that that thing that the
first meteorite ever found on Mars it
could put it in a museum and I believe
in humanity is what I'm trying to say
well that all sounds very promising I'm
glad that there are meteorites on Mars
and that curiosity has found them and I
hope that humans do go back to that
place and pick up that meteorite and
bring it home to earth as soon as 2029 I
think I think the museum is gonna be on
Mars John well that is not out of the
question as long as it's in 2028 or
later Hank AFC Wimbledon after losing to
Milton Keynes in difficult loss
absolutely pummeled Port Vale one of
those English towns that sounds like a
made-up place Port Vale lost that game
for
they could have lost eight nil their
goalkeeper had an extremely good game as
much as you can in a four nil loss and
it was just it was I mean to think this
season Hank in in league one where
everybody expected all the preseason
picks where AFC wimbledon was going to
finish last or second to last they were
definitely going to get relegated back
down to Ligue 2 right now they're in
ninth almost were almost exactly halfway
through the season Dom Polian scored his
12th goal of the season during that win
AFC Wimbledon they've looked not great
defensively at times but man they look
good going up front like Tom Elliot
scored Lyle Taylor started that game got
to got to play and had a big impact
Tyrone varnas scored a goal it's just
really really good performance and AFC
Wimbledon have scored more goals than
almost any team in Ligue 1 this season
they are just flying offensively and
it's you know I mean halfway through the
season in 9th place like I think the
goal is definitely still to avoid
relegation you need 52 points on average
from previous seasons if you get 52
points you'll probably um well almost
definitely escaped relegation right now
AFC Wimbledon has 32 points so they're
20 they would need only 20 points from
their last 24 games to ensure another
season in Ligue 1 but why not dream at
this point you know only three points
out of the last playoff position almost
halfway into the season pretty
extraordinary stuff from AFC Wimbledon
congratulations to that sports team they
are the best they are the best that was
my favorite thing about 2016 Hank being
able to go straight from the 100th
running of the Indy 500 to see AFC
Wimbledon win at Wembley with our dad
and rosianna and my friend Stuart and
Meredith it was just magical what was
your favorite part of 2016 Hank it's
gonna be a tough call for you but I'm
going to encourage you to pick the birth
of your child
they commit go with that uh yeah I mean
it's certainly something to do with the
child the birth was I don't know if I
can call it favorite because boy was it
a lot it was right pretty intense and
yeah but the the existence of my child
is definitely my favorite part well I
hope that 2017 brings even more
wonderful things into the world for you
personally and for all of the listeners
out there we're gonna take a couple
weeks off here at the beginning of the
year to celebrate the holiday and also
to work on some other stuff but we'll be
back soon you won't even notice that
we're gone I'm trying to work to work
together with some with some helpers to
get a best of 2016 episode of dear Hank
and John up so hopefully that will come
into your iTunes box or wherever you get
podcasts sometime during the holiday
season Catherine and I are gonna record
an episode together so be looking out
for that one as well oh so maybe we
aren't going to take any weeks off
you're just gonna have guest hosts Hank
what did we learn today
John we learned that it's we learned
that somebody had a 21st birthday and we
wish them a very happy birthday even
though we don't quite know who they are
we learned the difference between the US
government deficit and the US government
debt cuz that's what happens on advice
podcasts and of course we've learned
that it is ok with youtubers if you
watch youtubers on the toilet
poked away my friends thorpey whatever
just whatever that's your business
coming out that's you that's right
that's absolutely correct I finally I
apologize to everybody whose cookies
burned during this podcast John take us
out oh my god it's burning you can email
us at Hank and John at gmail.com that's
the place to send your questions or use
the hashtag dear Hank and John on the
Twitter where you can follow us I'm John
Green Hank is Hank green dear Hank and
John is produced by rosianna halse rojas
and sheridan Gibson our editor is
Nicholas Jenkins Victoria bon giorno is
our head of community and
Communications we should say that you
can always find lots of great stuff
including an opportunity to donate to
dear Hank and John at patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John our music is by the
great gunnarolla thank you so much to
gunnarolla for providing the theme music
Hank thanks for another great year of
potting and as we say in our hometown
don't forget to be awesome
[Music]